so as mine thank you very much for
inviting me to speak here so as
advertised on Chris Wiggins I'm related
mostly with Columbia University one day
week I'm at the new york times and i
thought i would divide our time into two
topics one is a bit of context about
what time what is the deal with data at
the new york times and then a bit about
what I've learned from comparing data
science as we know it in the Academy
with data science as it's done in the
real world for at least at the
narratives and by finding things that
are common maybe we'll find things that
are universal throughout all of data
science which since data science is not
really defined just easy to do so yes so
yeah so as promised i'm going to divide
this talking to two different parts so
i'll start with just a little bit of
context so a little bit of context your
background this is really a for the
actual talk i'll just let you know where
i'm coming from so here's what I'm
coming from where I'm coming from is I
started maybe in the early 90s doing
research in modeling biology which in
the early 90s most of biology a lot of
biology was done in the same way it was
done in the 19th century which is by
looking at stuff this for example is
motte-valois influenza is the first
slide identifying this critter and that
was sort of the prime modality of doing
things biology
time and still when you pick up figure 1
at most biology papers is a picture of
something right a picture of a slide or
a picture the gel or something like that
that's that sort of the throughput level
biology when I started trying to learn
physical models and biology and I was
coming from physics as a undergraduate
tradition and I thought well you know we
should use the style of modeling complex
systems that you have in physics to try
to understand things of biology which is
really an audacious goal because physics
is sort of all about systems where you
get to choose the complexity right when
it gets too complex you say with its
chemistry biology biology is just a mess
so it's a very audacious thought to
think that you can apply thinking of
physics to biology and I can still
remember the day in 1995 when a graduate
student came in carrying science
magazine and this was the cover image of
science magazine and this is the same
critter right 103 years later but
instead of being a picture of some thugs
and subs not which i think is what this
exit was this is the entire user's
manual for this critter write the entire
genome unfortunately it's been written
in a language you do not know right in a
language that only has four characters
and the language wasn't even written by
human who's written by some terrible
bias Monte Carlo algorithm so you were a
statistical task is to figure out what
the hell this this manual says in this
language that you do not know right and
that that sort of began a radical change
in the relationship between biology
numbers which was very exciting and very
painful so this was very painful time in
biology the late 90s as people started
to sequence whole critters including you
by the way
into the Millennium right humans have
been at least rough draft sequenced and
it was like it was a kind of pain that I
think you see and many other fields of
human endeavor you know like if you go
read the Moneyball book and you've got
people doing statistical analysis of
players and then there's other people
saying no look at his legs or look at
his girlfriends or whatever you know
covariance they were using before they
had data into value players that sort of
pain in the pain between people who are
quantitative and the people who are
doing in some other way you know I think
you see that pain happening to a lot of
fields if they become David rhew so that
was an exciting time and and and I think
that we learned a lot we human beings
learned a lot of lessons as biology
became data-driven that you see in other
fields so what did we do with this
knowledge what did we do with whole
genomes well here's an example of
something that we did and we can here by
we I don't mean humans I mean with me
and my co-authors a few years ago so an
example of what you might do when you
have a field that's been around for
centuries and by the way I should say
that I was not raised a biologist my
last biology classroom eighth grade and
we cut the phone and that's all I
remember about it but we my co-authors
and I one of the things we have an
example of what you might do when you
have abundant data is to take a question
like if you have a lot of genomes from
the same species but many different
individuals how might you say something
about the way those different
individuals have been evolving so the
sort of orthodox way since the 19th
century and this is X ray charles darwin
sketch from his notebook picturing the
origin of species maybe you have one
species and then it gets a
multiple species this is an excellent
model right and that it's interpretive
all it's not necessarily predictive but
it's a good model in the sense of being
interpreted and it doesn't really tell
you a lot about how to fit data to it
right and in fact if you've ever looked
at conferring phylogenetic trees as a
field you'll know that that's a very
complex filled with lots of people
arguing that they have the right way of
doing it so for example I was working
with some biologists and they had many
species of viruses that have been
evolving some of those viruses have been
evolving in pigs some have been evolving
in birds and you could think well I'm
going to do what uncle Charles said I
should do and I'm going to try to
impress a tree and maybe the furnace
will be over yonder very fluid will be
over yonder a pig flu will be over
yonder but that's really damn hard so
actually what we did was we just built a
classifier so we used a machine learning
algorithm that will tell you if you look
in a genome did it come from a pic or
did it come from a bird which I know
sounds like an academic question but if
you're saving government of China and
you flew breaks out of humans we would
have to decide should we kill all the
pigs or kill a little drinks that was
the kind of very implied question we're
picking it up and you know there's sort
of a lesson here from from Uncle
Vladimir from
as he likes to say don't solve a
difficult intermediate problem like
nutmeg likes to talk about not doing
density estimation and inference if you
want to do classification you should
just do classification so we didn't try
to build a tree we just said can you
build an algorithm that tells the
demonstrating pig viruses and converted
viruses we also wanted to do something
that was interpreted so we made the
primitive features in this model
questions that have meaning to
biologists like is this protein
substring present or not if so then add
some score and point 36 to your score
and then ask this next question by the
way if those of you who know this kind
of thing this is a boosted ultimatum
decision tree it's like a quantitative
game of 20 questions and at the end you
end up with the sum of scores such that
you get a high score if you will convert
and a low score if you're in a pig right
so this is an example of taking instead
of trying to do the tree thing which has
some intuition let's just turn it into a
prediction problem and then we don't
have to interpret the result of our
modeling we just ask our algorithm did
we get a plus 1 or minus 1 but we build
it out of primitive features such that
we stand a chance of going back to the
biologists in opening up the black box
and saying here's how the algorithm
works right and here's I don't
understand the working with this
algorithms into terms in terms of things
that are meaningful to you and those are
the sorts of tasks that I think carry
over well between what happens in
computational biology or data science
you know applying machine learning to
some particular domain and the business
world like when we say day designs in
the business world I find them
we're frequently doing the same thing
and qualitatively what I'm trying to do
in both of the times in combinational
biology is to take people's intuitions
and see if you can embody
intuitions and prediction algorithm in
this case the biologist has intuitions
that there are certain protein
substrates that matter do something and
so we want to ask we want to build a
interesting model out of very simple
features so that when you sum them
together you get something that's
predictive but then individual units are
themselves interpretive and that's what
we try to do I said that's what I find
that I'm trying to do frequently in the
real world how does this relate to the
room so you know that thing we now call
it data science applications of machine
learning
applications on machine learning to some
domain many companies right now I'm
doing that at scale left have web skip
right so you might work for company and
that company might have a website but
then your time for example has a website
right and that website is an opportunity
to collect abundant data so you may
think that data science is only the
purview of recent companies you know
companies like Google and Yahoo Facebook
group whoever this company is very old
but this is 163 year old company so it's
very exciting to be working there and
seeing how data is transforming a very
old industry and i should say it's not a
company that's um sitting still like you
think one had 63 year old it's an
incumbent what's exciting is that it's
an incumbent whose business model from
like 1851 through 2004 sort of
evaporated you know like the whole
structure of advertising via dead trees
just totally changed over the last
decade and so although it's an incumbent
in the sense that of being old you know
it's a company i'm very interested and
trying to figure out what is the future
of journalism like how do we build a
future of sustainable journalism where
the internet is the mechanism of
conveyance rather than the dead tree or
some combination of the boat so you
probably let me say a little bit about
what's happening with data at the
neurotoxins so there's some things that
you've probably seen a lot of it so for
example will be probably saying
interactive graphs of graphics at the
New York Times if you have it I urge you
to go look at this short URL
9 2013 for a nice review of all the
awesome things that the interactive news
team did in 2013 this is from a graphic
that shows you how the architecture of
New York James during the Bloomberg days
great interactive youth group you may be
aware that you're at times have no ideal
AB some of you may know my doer is from
the post lack of Miami's now they're
doing all sorts of cool or indie should
check out in mighty labs com to see a
lot of their beautiful projects the
things I'm going to talk about are
neither does it's neither public-facing
ignores a sort of R&D about what the
future of news that's like I should also
say before I talk about what I do New
York Times has a history of being a very
developer friendly company way back when
in my ancient times 2008 the New York
Times put out an API here's a here's a
blog post of that releasing an API so
you could search for things with this
listen uh no guy named James regimen but
now you know an example post where you
can access vapi such been here at times
content these api's are still active
just so you know that it's not talking
that was released in she doesn't even
put to sleep this is a postponed yeah
I'm spectral a of us no local Packard in
town where he saw somebody tweet it
would be cool if my whole music could be
the top news from the New York Times and
he wasn't built it using your time to
API so this is a live thing another
thing that I don't do but I think he's
implementing
how data feel like three times is maybe
of you have probably seen this new sheet
on section the upshot where many people
are advancing data journalism and I
think this is from the first day when
they release the upshot because my swing
that is Tuesday for 22 and they're not
just putting up new stories that are
data-informed they're actually sharing
their code which i think is super cool
so here's the github page for the upshot
is like section of the New York Times
where you can download code and you can
redo the story yourself if you'd like to
you know for many of us we've been
saying for years will be really cool in
terms of reproducibility of some day you
know mainstream media you know articles
will come with code and data and they're
actually doing that you can go and
download the Excel spreadsheets for some
of their data I'm not talking about any
of it that's cool Megan Cruz you invite
romantic Alex and everybody from those
teams that's not why I'm interested in
joining I'm not very good so I'm
interested in something else I'm
interested in the data that comes from
the abundant interactions between
everyone and company and the company
actually has a lot of data so you can go
to MIT cocom and you can see much more
data than I would release if I weren't
charged but you can see all sorts of
information about how many people have
been looking at the live site or veneer
times in the last hour at the last day
Tommy Cooper subscribing right there's a
lot of data there that's very much fun
on the back end so not public-facing
stuff that's going to become data
journalism not painted with
public-facing stuff that's going to
become interactive graphics just back
end stuff that you get just from having
a website there's a lot of data that you
have to try to understand how people
engage with your product right it's a
bit like doing user surveys except that
ridiculous scale right so that's the
kind of thing that I think is very
exciting about trying to apply data
science at the New York Times that's the
kind of thing that I'm interested in
this is not new news that the new york
times is a website that has
just to sort of put things in
perspective New York Times was featured
prominently in this story from 60
minutes you can see he is terrified of
the New York Times like is letting other
than hearing times it's involved in
collecting your data there are times
does not sell your data to other people
repetition put that in perspective
although some of you may have seen the
news Newton x is an example of a website
that which means you know there's all
sorts of tools that you have as a
website for figuring out how people are
engaging with your product like so this
is an example on how the New York Times
uses other services some of you may know
this company which is here in New York
the point is anyone who has a website
has a the opportunity to list them to
their customers at scale wait like
everyone who interacts with your product
is telling you how they feel about your
product right in New York Times have a
pretty manifold product by multiple
articles multiple answers beats features
it also has subscriptions there's lots
and lots of data to help the New York
Times understand better what people like
why people stick around if they stick
around all those things that you would
normally do by you know doing customer
surveys you can really do that scale if
you have a website which print onto the
website so the kind of thing you might
think to do is something like we did
with viruses you know like wouldn't it
be cool if you could just take all of
the different attributes of people
looking at your company aren't looking
at your website and figure out you know
could you tell the difference between
people who are looking at a type or
another pretty teletype you know people
who do one thing or another thing that
is the analog of figuring out who's this
virus coming from pigs start from first
right if you have something that you
know that's business great if you could
take a lot of those data
and do machine lighting on it the same
way that people do in computational
biology or in moneyball or in May other
fields as it sound you're stood that's
the kind of thing that I think is an
exciting opportunity for many companies
including three million times for
example the New York Times doesn't have
a short well the New York Times aims not
to have short-term relationships with
its readers right it's trying to create
a community of people who are loyal
readers so you might ask you know what
is the genome like of loyal subscribers
is there some way that you can figure
out from the way people interact with
the product is this does this look like
somebody who's loyal subscriber or
somebody who's not well subscribe who's
gonna who's going to stay and who's
going to go and why why did they
cigarette right and so that's the analog
here if you know their business
questions that you like to ask you'd
like to frame these prediction problems
in such a way that they work you know
that the predictive we'd also like to
have to be interpretive up so you can
actually help people help you normal
people people who have questions that's
what I think is exciting about working
at the narratives and again you know the
idea of doing machine learning is
approaching is probably using machine
learning it's different from traditional
ways of thinking about your customers
I'm not trying to bring people into
segments like soccer moms and kind of
dance or blue or something like that I
just want to look at the data and let
the data tell me what are the attributes
that turned out to be predictive but I
want my primitive features here to be
features that are individually
interpretable so I can work with people
and answer questions from a particular
domain just like you do in data science
in any field so I want to move from the
intuition to the prediction so on I mean
one of the one of the pieces of context
about working at a place like the New
York Times is it's it's still data
science just like you know we do in
academia when you take that machine
learning you try to
to a science of biology but you get to
do it with the web and the web you know
before I started working with your time
and I thought of the way of this like
online presence purex the bureau
publisher then the web is way for you to
put your content out there like it's
sort of like a replacement for the dead
tree but it's much more like that much
more than that and so something that's
been exciting to realize is that it's
also a microscope right so just because
you have a company a gypsy go to our
website and you have a microscope and to
let all your your users or your
subscribers want right what they like
they like it what makes them come back
what's correlated with the oil tea
what's correlated with no loyalty
something else that you can get exciting
in which i'll talk a little bit about is
it's also an experimental tool so right
every time anybody says oh they're going
to a being tested right they're using
the web as an experimental tool so our
website is not just a place for you to
put your content online it's a place for
you to look at your users I can see what
they like but it's also good for you to
experiment I'll say a little bit more
than that and something that's exciting
although I don't really have much to say
about this is that lab is also an
optimization tool right you can script
what content you provide to people so
there's nothing to stop you from picking
up the web as an organization and I
would not say that that's particularly
true of the you know times you know what
what determines what you see is news
judgment at any rate times it's not it's
not the case that things are being
optimized like you're seeing something
that's very carefully curated and
I think is part of the reason why the
company still exists but it's something
for you to think about every time you
have a website you have much more than
just a place to put your stuff if you
have a chance to interact with your
customers to perform experiments before
performing optimization that's all the
context I wanted to say now that I've
said something about the context and
like we're coming from them I thought
I'd say what I've learned so I thought
I'd say things that I've learned that
are the same what leaves very common
between data science says it's done in
the Academy I'm trying to do besides for
biology say and data science in the real
world context paper business so done
with the header let me actually help the
body of the top so let me say a few
words about what I think our common
requirements and data science and some
of you are data scientists some of you
or aspiring data scientists some of you
manage data scientists who are very
pretty damn something so just so i know
my eyes how many of you are Dave
scientist how many of you are aspiring
data scientists how many of you manage
data scientists okay so that's a pretty
even mix I have to say so here are
things that I think that you should
either demand of yourself or of the
people of your manage that you manage
for demand of yourself once you become a
data scientist in the future and these
are requirements that I think I there
because they see the same thing in real
world that I see in
computational biology point data science
of life sciences so then I've broken
these up into a few different ideas one
is a set of practices if there are
certain practices that they think are
just good hygiene for being a data
scientist in the world we should demand
these practices of yourself and people
need managed separately are copied
skills like the things that you do that
made you a data scientist to nonsense
and then more loosely culture like
there's a set of cultural practices that
I think are common between data
scientists from the sciences and data
science and business so practice what
are some of the practices of a data
scientist that I think are common
between the two loops one is the desire
and the ability to reframe the main
questions as machine learning tasks so
an example I already alluded to was
let's say that you would like to know if
you give me a virus can I tell you it
was a pig virus or burglars that's a
humane question but I could reframe that
as a prediction problem I want to have
an algorithm which takes as input your
genome or genome translated into amino
acid sequence for so protein segments
and takes its output a number such that
that number is positive with your pig
virus omega-3 products so that's an
example of reframing at the main
question is extremely task that's only
useful to people from the domain if at
the end you're able to go tell them why
the thing worked I mean it's an
engineering win if you get a model
that's predictive it's a science win if
you can tell them why you can tell them
what are the features that actually
discriminate between pigs birds um this
was particularly a problem in biology
because you know um when people started
sequencing whole critters then they
started doing things like measuring the
on/off state of every gene
at once and there's just no rules about
what statistics you did I mean if you
look at those papers in computational
biology it really looks a lot like
amateur baseball statistics people would
just do whatever with data right because
there's no models to compare to know
models to fit you very little absolutely
it's not like f equals ma and then you
compare F equals MA to this hairball
geez so there was a lot of a lot to be
learned in those early days it was very
difficult to take questions of interest
like what gene is controlling which
other gene that's a demain question and
really framed it as a particular machine
like a test that's difficult another
practice that I think people who do data
science should keep in mind is it's much
better to be wrong than to do something
that's nice so this hair ball is not
wrong right this is neither right or
wrong so this is just a picture that you
can get from a scientific publication
about a bunch of jeans and they interact
with each other maybe gene 137 is
connected to ginseng season it's sort of
an art project it's not something that
really can be made false as opposed to
like the output of a supervised learning
algorithm right you can hold out data
and you can see is my model right or
wrong and it's I think it's a far better
practice for you to try to build models
that can be wrong than to build
something that's kind of cool to look at
right and it's liable I think also
that's a piece of career advice that
I've given to my students who have gone
into startups is try to do some data
science that's relevant to the product
and realized
this model because when times get tough
if you're just doing something that's
nice you're going to be expendable right
you don't want to do something that's
just kind of cool to have around you
want to do something that's addressing
some core business government and that's
actually relevant to the professor so
ready to be wrong and to do something
that's just cool to look at another
difficult task is to be relevant so for
example be another thing about China
right they actually do have to kill
birds and eggs right so try to predict
the thing that's actually relevant to
something that's a clear use case some
people you're trying to collaborate and
this is not as easy as it sounds because
you can do statistics on lots of
different stuff right but there's a
difference between say saying I'm going
to look at it the player attributes for
every player on my team and predict how
many wins because people care about wins
and I'm gonna look at all the player
attributes and I'm going to rank players
by some statistic I just made up such
that Derek Jeter is the best and then
you can definitely see that kind of
style of fun in a maternity baseball
statistics and sometimes in
computational biology so try to focus on
something that's actually relevant to
the people with whom you're
collaborating this is not so easy for
example there was a twitter for Tuffle
recently about what are the metrics that
you should be looking at for news so
here's the truth from tony hale maybe
you're maintaining a always to see you
know charkie saying you know we found no
correlation between social shares and
people actually read what does it mean
it means if you're let's say your
publisher like the New York Times and
you'd like to know that you're
generating content that people find
engaging engaging can be quantified in
like seven different ways give yourself
half an hour and you
72 maybe 10 different ways of modifying
engagement what is how much of people
sharing it you know like if you go to
the Maritimes one thing you can do is
you click on the button that says mail
this story to my grandma you could just
mail URL but there's button you can use
that for tracking sharing and people
actually reading well part of Tony's
company is to sell a tool that would
allow you to look at the actual time
that people are spent on a page so try
pink will help well tell you how long
you put on the page there scroll depth
that'll tell you about your metrics
about how you've engaged other than did
you click or did you not click so which
only saying here is you know other
companies that might be telling you
we're going to make your stuff really
viral we're going to make people sharing
your stuff he's saying that's actually
relevant because people actually reading
the stuff is not correlated with how
they share well I mean how did they find
that out if it's not like you can go to
downloads to get hub and download all
the data bay use its 140 characters so
another step in this particular Twitter
kotoko was this response from Jonah
Peretti again this is not happening
appearing to your publications or even
when i get up this is happening 140
characters Jonah saying well actually
I'll BuzzFeed sharing increases let's
get to spend more time reading so and
then he proves it with this text but
some soft feather yeah that you may or
may not used so he you know it's very
difficult to know if you're measuring
the right thing in the real world so
these are people who give their founders
right they spent all day day thinking
about how to quantify engagement with
publications right it's still very
difficult to know are you optimizing
the right thing Tony's advocating for
optimizing how much you read are you
saying it doesn't correlate with how
much your share Joan is interested in
how much you share join up by the way
who's the founder BuzzFeed BuzzFeed
spends a lot of time looking at how much
people share their content yes please
thank you for being a brave person first
ask your question yeah so like no the
pharmaceutically student science biology
happening of not having a declarative
hypothesis is very interesting because
the deer that you get like out of a
genome-wide map for example is great
forming the next type offices so let's
say the data funny
when you want to consider some other day
because you learn something new about
some other gene that somebody else
studies by having a declarative
hypothesis I kind of like the picture on
the right you're sort of limiting your
scope you're just answering one kind of
question to once when you're ignoring
all the data that's out there is that
the word of hope I'm not advocating for
hypotheses what am advocating is for
doing statistical methods where at the
end you know if it was good or bad right
i mean this is for example why people
put p values on things right yeah so
irrespective of what you think your
hypothesis i can put a p-value wanted
okay let's talk about few guys I don't I
know your please don't go I can't bear
you don't I guess yeah I'm again I'm a
convention look I can put a value
because you do that but what I mean by
that is not that there should be one
hypothesis that you're testing you can
go into something with no particular
hypothesis for in a way what I'm doing
is I'm going I'm going in here with the
zillions of hypotheses and I'm allowing
the data to define the model for me for
example my hypothesis is that some non
linear combination of presence or
absence will follow the possible 20 to
the 10 you know 10 murs of amino acids
some lone linear combination of them is
going to convey predictive power that's
not one hypothesis right that's an
extremely high dimensional
hypotheses right in fact in the business
this would be called hypothesis space so
part of the machine my mindset is not to
go into it with one night one hypothesis
at all but to have some controlled and
finite dimensional space of hypotheses
and allow the data to reveal to you what
is the hypothesis that has the most
power and power here doesn't necessarily
mean p value that means the ability to
make accurate predictions and held out
data so keep in your mind three
different mindsets one is the scientific
method as it was told to you in fifth
grade maybe semi garden I think you
should start with the hypothesis another
is that you should take that hypothesis
you should be p value on it relative to
some particular male model then if you
want me to all go into problems with
that particularly if you're multi very
prompt don't start it and another is to
create a high-dimensional but finite
dimensional space or possible hypotheses
models and allow and use the right math
to tell you which of those models is the
model that makes the most accurate
predictions on held updated in the third
of those I think of Israeli the machine
learning lesson so I'm not at all saying
that on you you should choose one
hypothesis right in fact the machine or
anything to do is to carve out some
finite hypothesis space and then this is
one graphic representation of one model
it comes out so instead of picking out
one hypothesis in advance you have a
high-dimensional possibly infinite
number of hypotheses can you let the day
to decide for you what is the right mom
Thanks when you associate a hypothesis
with a prediction what I mean by being
wrong is it spits out a number and you
can leave out data and see did you get
it right along it's a model well the
language hybrid use is that it's an
example of supervised learning rather
than unsupervised or anywhere you have a
particular label you are trying to
predict and I leave out that label I
leave out some data and then armed with
new data I try to see if my modern exact
your predictions of that label in hell
that day which is a very is a small city
with incontinent statistics which others
it's a big climate without any
resistance and within my cotton is a
small island but country called
supervised learning and that is a place
where I can sleep well at night because
at the end I know whether or not i
atleast knew that I could have been
wrong right and if my model generate
gets it right fifty percent of the time
and the data is the data are distributed
with fifty percent bias that I know that
I've been it's crap right and it's nice
to know that at least it would have been
possible to have great push not all
statistical methods with it Russ
okay so being relevant so you know these
are these are statistical questions
being asked for real business purpose
right tony has a company that can tell
you how long people are on the page are
they saying you should measure how long
people have been on the page Jonah has a
company that where they keep track of
how much people share stuff and he's
telling you should keep tracking how
much we can share stuff right so again
this is it's a difficult thing to be
relevant into to do statistics in a way
that's a dresser with a clear business
purpose and these fights are not always
played out in peer-reviewed publications
where of course everyone shares their
data under code right i mean so even in
peer-reviewed publications is difficult
to know like our people registering the
right thing and a during the right way
let alone be real let alone on twitter
140 simulacra but the real life so it's
difficult to be relevant let's say you
are a website mind if you are a website
you have to decide do i want to optimize
how much people share how long do people
spend on the page not even optimize
should I even be looking at them and if
you've been following there's a lot of
publications the spring about having
journalism there's some publications
where the journalists are not even
allowed to ask those questions there are
some publications that don't allow the
journalists to look at their metrics but
let's say you forget about the general
scrub at life on the business side
should I be trying to get people to read
a story to click on a story to spend a
lot of time story to scroll all the way
down to go buy stuff I don't think
there's a link here for buy stuff but
maybe I want to get people to do blend
t-shirt maybe I want people to subscribe
you know people to register there's a
lotta different ways to quantify
engagement right and this is just one
company whatever company you're
associated with find something that's
quantifiable and that's relevant to the
people who are not running are you find
the thing that's relevant and is it is
clearly of business relatives make it
will save you your job it'll keep you
from just calculating
number things and it helped engage
people in the fact that data are
valuable so that's one practice
hypotheses hypotheses are not the same
as data jeopardy so one thing that
happens a lot of biology is is donated
turn a found data so some
experimentalist does some experiment and
then they hand you several megabytes or
gigabytes of data and say here cluster
this make it for free because I have NIH
proposal dude similarly in business like
you have a website it's spitting out
lots of data all the time just sort of
munging those data and repackaging
saying you know there's the meeting in
the six you know it's not the same as
actually trying to say are people who
are sharing also reading more or right
they don't right that would be an
example of hypothesis you might try to
uncover by looking at the data right and
that's a hypothesis that does have
business relevance for example to Talia
joy they have companies where their
businesses are sort of about sharing of
you go viral so it's nice when you can
go into a problem and actually have some
hypotheses you have some clear direction
rather than just screwing with the data
until Derek Jeter is the best so going
into data with hypotheses is great but
sometimes you fight with the data you
have and not the day do you want how do
you go about getting the day you want
well befriend experimentalists so
painful lesson for me from biology is
that it's very different to just do some
analysis on somebody's data even even if
you go and show the experimentalist who
took the data it's very different than
actually working with an experimentalist
to come up with the experiment
themselves and this is not your news
right so when you were in kindergarten
somebody told you about the scientific
method here's somebody's being played in
pre-k right they talk to me when I was
very young in bed
method as we said earlier is you go in
with I pollicis and then you do it you
think of an experiment that we possibly
falsify the hypothesis and then going to
work so what kind of what was the kind
of thing that happens in biology here's
an example taken from the paper i
published about a decade ago where we
said well looking at east you can see
that these particular sequence elements
are hugely important for yeast doing
what it does and so if that's true then
we want a biologist to go knock out
which means to delete these sequence
elements from east and make sure that
you is broken and say so 2004 i went and
showed this list to a very high like a
senior used to experimentalist i said
please would you do this experiment and
the biologist said well these are
obvious and these are nuts and this has
been seen in some cousin of yeast and
this one maybe i'll get an undergraduate
to do some day check back with me in six
months right so you doing some analysis
without an experimentalist involved and
engaged lowers the probability that some
experimental actually action on your
insights and i was thinking of that
conversation a little while ago when i
did something similar at the new york
times but i can't tell you what it is
but trust me that this is super cool
stuff I can't tell you what we did when
we did something super cool and I said
look this attribute is hugely hugely
important this is a really important
attribute this was a pretty real
important attribute let's go do some
experiments and Tesla's and I showed it
to somebody who's not a quantitative
person in that person said well this
thing over here kinda reminds me of
something in facebook this thing over
here is kind of good so maybe we'll look
into that from legend six months so it
was like the same experiment I had
biologist a decade earlier so it is
really helpful to befriend
experimentalist and the experimentalists
in the real world are people who like to
fraud but the people who have permission
to actually write the code that is going
to change the website those are the
people you want to make friends are so
at the narrow times we have different
people who controls family's dr. kress
dr. Crespo or somewhere out of my name's
that they should be tell you about
experiments that are done in maritime
you'd like to make friends with people
who actually can action your insights
because otherwise you're just going to
make a list of things that are really
important where you think are important
and try to get some pretty action it's
much better to go into an analysis
hand-in-hand with the person who
actually writes to prod the person
ryerson controls the site in the world
for a small company that's much easier
for a bigger company you might have to
go find them first before you start
doing for analysis so that is a lesson
my subject matter expert somebody goes
to describe the data
vs
well I mean so I think the job of the
data scientist is to speak subject
matter as well so you know like it's not
enough to just get epsilon better
performance with you're introducing
incredible public space right like the
job of the data scientist should be to
be communicative than the domain of
demand right you should be able to
communicate with subject matter experts
under saying for a big company you might
do some analysis and then like getting
somebody else to actually on a half of
the fact he's going to be a lot harder
than if you engage with them first and
get them to walk hand in hand with you
towards the analysis they're more likely
to actually action on it let's surf
winter result you come together hand in
here right so in biology this happens
all the time you get a theoretical
physicists and biologists and sometimes
they iterate really well like turn years
later no I can you do something if your
medical physics and then two years later
somebody does an experiment then five
years later remember i did a theoretical
calculation to 97 and then like somebody
verified it like 2006 right but like the
real world it would be nice to move
faster than nine years to get a
relationship between predictions and so
many actioning on it so the best way to
do it is you know like when theoretical
physicists and biologists pair up and
they say we think this mechanism is cool
let us together go do an experiment and
so that's a piece of advice for data
scientists in the real world is it's a
lot easier to get people actions if you
go into with the person who writes to
provide or owns the business question or
something like that rather than doing
analysis and brushing them afterwards
school stuff and you know same thing in
biology biology it's a little easier to
download people's data now but I'm
really the same sort of social sort of a
social engineering observation make
things with the people who do
experiments okay so that sort of
practices let me say a few things about
actual skills and what are the actual
skills thing that I want my students to
know in academia and that my
collaborators and I drop it from within
the real world one thing is to find
quantifiable so find some quantitative
measure of good so that when you just do
an infinite number of different
manipulations of your data you know
whether things are getting better at
worse so if somebody hands you a bunch
of data and your new manipulation one
and you make a picture having you
manipulation to make a different picture
that algorithm and my experience w
converge it's far better if in advance
you say usually because of some domain
reason I know that I want to optimize a
you see on held out data for you know
rmse normalized by the variance or some
figure of Merit that everyone is going
to agree is a clear quantitative scalar
metrics so that as you start doing
different manipulations you know what
you're getting closer to the truth they
will probably might indicate if you just
do if you make one scatterplot then the
next day you make a difference kind of
mark it's like to know if you've got the
question and truth the further away from
the corollary did this is choose
carefully so choose very carefully what
you think is your your figure thing like
put into the date here anyway fitting to
the data is not necessarily good one
because tomorrow you might have new
fudge factors you might you have your
free parameters if you put the data
better
doesn't necessarily mean you have a
better month assuming that sets of a
prediction so choose carefully what is
the figure of merit but choose some
Plantin figure it now this is something
I found useful the other thing is do the
dumbest possible thing first so
occasionally I work with people students
or collaborators in the real world and
the first sight is we are going to deep
learning this thing with the infinite
stack of de Richelieu hierarchical
Chinese restaurant of a face or
something like latest thing that they
just read about please always do the
dumb thing first is this thing I saved
my students into my collaborators like
just benchmarking against pcj please
because chapter you know page 4 page 5
of the paper if you're going to have to
compare to the strongman anyway so just
do that first because then once you're
done lva with you know deep learning or
whatever then you can say you know we'd
be pca by a factor of 10 just just do
the dumb thing first because and on the
other thing is if it doesn't work with
the dumb thing at all no should wait a
little bit with the dumpling then maybe
there's some problem in the way you
kinda brought the analysis remember this
problem with your day so I will echo
this wise tweet from up from 2012 you
know like when you're doing something
real world go read a couple publications
where people do some fancy pants New
method look at the method that they all
say oh this is much better than that
simple method try that method first
you're going to have to benchmark
against it anyway so do that method
first and so before you do a graphical
model with a nested stack of plates and
some extra fancy nodes over here see if
you can do a graphical model just just
three notes do the simple fingers
the other thing is before you spend a
lot of time doing massive feature
engineer before you spend a lot of time
figuring out that one of my features
should be this thing that I have to ride
a MapReduce job that takes a day to run
and it calculates the scenario fancy
statistic just try to build a regression
model was really easy to get features
first just again just to make sure that
things are working and sensible before
you start spending all the time I
feature engineering because a lot of
times the thing that the rate-limiting
step is actually something very dumb
that's just a complete blocker before
you waste a lot of time building the
right set of features this is an example
of you know for distributions that I
think I'll say mean variance or so they
were thankful you can fit them all to a
straight line it's okay you know later
you can go back and look at the scatter
plots and see if maybe you shouldn't
just fit them all to straight line first
just try fitting into a straight line
because nothing's broken then you'll see
it renovate the other thing is before
you do they decide you will probably
have to do a lot of data engineering so
you know we're here at a meeting about
data science and there's a lot of
attention of data science there's far
less attention to what used to be called
et al which is now called data
engineering like the ability to extract
transform and load lawrence datasets
particularly in the real world like if
you work for companies another website
somebody is going to need to do the
difficult David engineering like
maintaining making accessible lots and
lots of data and making those data small
enough that you can put it into your
favorite piece of software and do some
small data analysis with you there will
have to be some dimensional and this is
a Gurkha go read this folds and short
blog posts just saying let's praise day
in tips is it true you know everybody is
doing dating sites almost all the data
science were doing particularly you know
head web-scale you wouldn't be able to
do it unless
Engineers marriage ok so those are some
skills points that is you will need
either to know how to direct data
engineering where you need to be
incoming that's big enough that have
they have good data engineers let me
make some cultural points about vega
science and again these are culture
place that i think are true both in
academia real world one thing and to
speak to other question is to be like
the thing that makes your data scientist
and not merely the machine motor again
miss you man is very hard but the thing
that people often say is the
differentiator between data science and
machine learning is your ability to
listen well to domain problems to be
creative about reframing those problems
as machine learning tasks and then to
communicate to people what you learned
right why does your model work what did
you learn why did you do it that way be
communicated that I think of it as a key
skill of being a data scientist another
way of saying being communicative is to
promote rhetorical literacy like make it
fast aisle for the people around you
students collaborators business partners
to speak machine right it doesn't
doesn't help anybody it doesn't even
help you in the long term if you try to
be the only person who speaks data well
you want to be a community where
everybody is able to speak at least
rhetorically about data even if they
can't you know do the stuff it would be
good if you're an environment where
people have least know what you're doing
again I think that's also good for your
job you know if you're if you're doing
this kind of freaky stuff and it's
ancillary to
business and the business gets rough you
don't want to be the person is doing
something ancillary freaky you want to
be doing something that everybody sort
of seems like hot this shapes the way we
do fit too so promote rhetorical owners
promote the ability of everyone around
you to make arguments with data and to
understand the methods you use one way
to do that is to build models that have
both predictive and interpretable so
interprete before example built out of
easy to understand yes no questions
where those yes/no questions are based
on features that are meaningful to the
domain experts as opposed to say
k-nearest neighbors it's okay kenyatta
neighbors might be great for your
problem but like you're not gonna be
able to summarize how this thing works
you know well the way this thing works
is you look at your 600 neighbors and
these are training examples it's a
template in a model or so if nothing
else sort of small feature set and you
can say these are the features that
matter this is what makes the different
pic viruses including android viruses
maybe it's just like well we had these
viruses in this one level it's close to
that one under some definition so it is
a it's part of being a good data
scientist to be able to have a versatile
set of tools so you are able to
construct tools that are both predictive
and interpret another type of literacy
is skepticism it and of course the
person about whom you should you know
skeptical as yourself right so when you
have a good result and you get some good
at R squared or you get whatever KP
adios ping you know make the extra
scatter plot to make sure that you're
not throwing yourself that this is an
example when you put some things to a
straight line and you're thinking odds
this but maybe you should look at the
residuals like this is something we've
done what the doc statistician for
children Roy looking scatterplot after
going to the residuals see if there's a
trend in residuals be critical and have
the ability to take just a little bit
deeper and make sure
do not less promoting that critical
literacy also means empowering the
people that work around you even if
they're not the people who are writing
are never you know promote the ability
of other people to question it and to
make sure that you're not doing
something that nuts so promoting
critical literacy i think is useful and
this is certainly true for my biologist
collaborators right like I want them to
know what I'm doing enough that they
feel comfortable doubting right and they
feel comfortable asking hard questions
about why my methods are doing a bidding
be empowering sharing your tools right
put your coat on get up use simple tools
like art that other people can use right
that's something that guy to do but I
should go go to big league / Wiggins lab
we've distribute all the source code for
all my methods sometimes in our
sometimes a matlab sometimes the Python
whatever tools we're using one other
people to be able to use them so be in
town so that other people can you know
speak data with you and then all of you
can do more data path skipping be
transparent but don't try to be don't
try to do smokey emeritus with what
you're doing just try to explain it in a
way that makes it makes other people
feel like they know what that you're
doing again I think that's also working
a career um promoting this literacy as i
said is really about then turn Eva types
of literacies promoting functional that
RC means letting other people actually
do this stuff like can they run our can
they know stuff in the right library can
we do the analysis critical literacy
means can they talk back can they ask
you really insightful questions but we
should be which which they may be able
to do even if they don't know how to do
the stuff be incredible big literacy
critical literacy is different than
functional literacy and rhetorical
diversity promote other people having
the ability to make arguments using day
and I'm not making this up all of this
edges and totally stealing from an old
argument about computational literacy so
you know ten years ago
people were making this argument about
computational inner-city the
computational literacy is really three
different kinds of things go read some
of this whole reading multi literacy and
just run it through a set script that
replaces computational with algorithms
and it sounds totally present if you
take this stuff and you just read it you
said put your good blog it tomorrow if
you were saying you were a bum some data
scientist very perfect because it's the
same insights but like it we can really
promote a much more data-driven set of
companies have culture or set of
Sciences by making it possible and
empowering the people who work around us
to have these different types of the
nurses even if they never need to give
you a thing ever learn how to code which
is just a function like working with
people and encouraging them to be able
to make arguments with data and to be
able to be skeptical of data arguments
Israelis distance the point about using
not using k-nearest neighbors or
lexified need to use neural networks out
of an apology let's say that is
how do I go about getting that one of
them over a spinning back okay so you're
doing good ready till the point where
you said optimal because then you really
open yourself up the snack and say AHA
but you know how do you define optimal
what makes a good model a good model is
both predictive and interpret and we
choose whether we want to design you
know whether our desiderata is de
minimis predictive power or interpreter
building which one makes you write often
you know you might do something random
forest and for some problems and might
set a near upper boundary predictive
power but it's got a damn hard to
explain to people you know so
benchmarking against logistic regression
just try it first once let's just just
do the dumb thing once right and it may
be that the things that turn out to have
huge Gini coefficient or whatever also
turn out to be the things with big
coefficients and it's going to be a lot
easier to explain to people the thing in
terms of big coefficients then it will
be well I have a set of a thousand
randomly generated trees where I did dry
but if I said I'm try to five then I
didn't want to go I just want to say
like these are the pictures that really
matter and they have discriminative
pouch great venues Jews JLM net when you
can still get pretty good predictive
power yeah sorry this is an arguable so
I should know that should be giving
props toward yes please
we find a subject matter expert so my
question is why did I
when they really needed to hire a
marketing marketing mba with art there's
many ways to answer that question
anytime's anybody asking your question
of why 12 oh look they're already hard
really great people with NBA skills I
don't know if there's I don't how many
people are both MBAs and encode and are
within the building but they're already
like ours really mid people in the
marketing department with great domain
expertise work with them love them learn
from them great Dan Brown I don't know
historical accident you know I went to
Mike Hanson less year and have a
sabbatical what should I do with my
sabbatical he said do something nutty
like go to the new york times he
introduced me to somebody who was over
the tech division you know I mean why
you know why why was hewlett-packard's
first customer Disney it was really just
the randomness of just this person
happen to know that person but i will
tell them when i get that they should
fire my ass
and iron NBN speaks on I don't know I
mean look come with me to the 10th floor
where we're able to kick ass together
using your NBA skill my life I work in
the pharmaceutical industry I said this
is very entertaining to me to see
because I'm on high yeah look Peyton
town it is clearly not a lot on his left
via data scientists may have most people
are calling themselves data scientists
good variety of backgrounds so sure I
mean if you can convince somebody to
hire an NBA team speaks all right
awesome rock it out and you know maybe
this behaves big sorrel be able to
employ all these skills like I think
that's great I don't I don't think you
necessarily need to hire CPUs
accommodation villages I do think though
that there are some commonalities
between dealing with really messy data
and dealing with people who have domain
expertise questions that are not yet
machine learning tasks and the creative
ask the creative task of trying to
reframe those two main questions as
machine running tasks and then
communicate what you've learned back to
the domain expert and those I think are
very common in all of data science
whether that's a shame applied biology
machine when you're fighting marketing
chew on in a blender baseball a lot of
different place I mean the simple answer
to why is you know it's just I knew this
guy here that guy which is with the way
most people get hired anywhere
I'm going to put on my marking
eventually the people who really care
about this are people who are selling
the advertising in one way or another
whether it's directly or through some
math yet work or something
you said something about that you're not
looking to have segments you're looking
to have modeled attributes I can't kind
of explain that further because I'm just
so used to the only people on the
service yeah segments uh I guess alls
I'm saying is you know segments are not
bad and like people speak segments but
it reminded me a lot of in this problem
where we were trying to figure out if
these viruses came from burnt debates
and the dominant paradigm in that field
is to build a phylogenetic tree that's a
very difficult intermediate step right
so let's say you're in marketing or
advertising and you have intuitions in
your brain maybe there are exist thing
called soccer moms it may be there
exists a thing called frequent travelers
and Macbeth then when you stop like when
do you stop making up segments and then
how do you know if you've designed your
segments right that's a very difficult
intermediate task whereas you might want
to know something simpler like by these
people going to come back right and
that's a prediction problem and you can
frame it as a prediction problem in
terms of many attributes without ever
having to do a really difficult
intermediate to ask life to finding a
bunch of segments in terms of soccer
moms and diehard fav see other you know
social constructs right so alls I'm
saying is the same thing but above neck
legs to say which is when you have a
statistical task don't try to do so much
more difficult statistical task as an
immediate step like conferring a
phylogenetic tree has a definite
identifiability problem in statistical
parlance by giving a finite number of
genomes it's very difficult to say I
have this one tree and then you break up
it though like two different games and
gang is all about integrating over trees
another game is fighting about the best
tree which can fight you don't go there
if you want to just tell the genome will
come from a peg or a bird then just
build a classifier that tells where they
came from so that's really what I'm
getting it let's say that you have a
bunch of people you have something that
you know it's business relevant like did
they come back or not then you might be
able to build a classifier with that
very very difficult intermediate to ask
of saying I believe that there are five
types of people soccer moms diehard eggs
and a bunch of the things I'm the
Builder which set rules we're going to
identify those people so look for cases
where you can just let go and let art
look for if you look for places where
you can let the map guide you rather
than doing difficult intermediate steps
I think of segmentation is a very
difficult thing right to sort of to have
prior intuition about who your audiences
segmentation is nice because what you
learn in one context you can use in
another context I get that right maybe
once you once you know that they have
this iteration with your product maybe
you also believe that you might
advertise the rotisserie such a way it
helps generate hypotheses have an
employee and then do it predictive tree
or logistic regression don't bother
doing
you know hierarchical clustering models
and then doing individual trees just
felt felt for answering your question
and don't worry about whether their
particular people might not be that
great fourth of the month cuz I mean I
work with people who like to do say so I
would say don't worry because I wear
your own time but in particular you know
when you have things that you get wrong
one of the one of the things that you do
is to look at residuals or in the
context of a classifier look at the
things where you predicted plus one and
really this bad but you know is named so
I certainly believe looking at what you
got wrong and in fact looking at what
you got wrong is where the artificial
artificial intelligence happens that's
where you are the learn when you look at
the examples that you get wrong you were
the one who figures out what are the
patterns that are outside this set of
features that are in their model right
your mother your model isn't so I
thought that this space circumscribed by
the set of features and if you see a
bunch of things that you're getting
really freakishly wrong look at them and
it may be that there's a pattern that
you will die using your brain rather
than your fingers and then use that to
inform your mom other heinous please
you said be friends with experimental
and I want to drive on that in in your
own field in biology perhaps long-term
hypothesis given that any
keep going back now I'm wondering from
all the hip described so far you're
teaching me a little bit rubbish one
iteration you saying okay I'm going to
do this prediction and I'm done and my
question is can you can you pick can you
take what we have understood and then
log back to the marketing guys I said I
look you know what if you were to do
this additional pain you might find more
you know perhaps a new direct marketing
fatigue or much like you know I'm
skinning beyond just baby testing that
I'm saying that could you could you run
this iteration more than once right so
the answer your question is yes and this
is precisely has statistical model works
so this is there's a very old articles
in what the literature in statistics
about the aeration between model
building and running experiments that
there was a great article Dave my
columbia college babe I just put out
this article in January about iteration
and graphical modeling so to come back
to the previous questioner yes look at
what you get wrong right and it's not
the case that if you build a model and
then the bill
it's an experiment and then you convince
your experiments friends of your
experiment can you get it right but that
naturally suggested it I'm a hypothesis
the new hypothesis suggested when you
look at what you got wrong another way
of putting it is you know I've heard
several Nobel Prize winner is
interviewed over the years and they
never say that their economic was Eureka
they always say that their Eureka moment
was nuts you know that you know they're
looking at their apparatus and their
apparatus is supposed to ping and
instead of palms and something totally
outside their current understanding of
what happened and drilling down into
whatever there is where they generate
hypotheses and understood I think all of
this model building is very useful for
it you know well like the thing that you
do when you're just doing learning
without experiments can be very useful
like if you're letting the math tell you
the right model from a space of possible
models that's possible and that's up you
know as much as you can learn with the
dead data set you're going to hand it if
you really want to go beyond that you
need to make friends with an
experimentalist and see what the model
that you learn from brier data gets
radically wrong in the center content
and looking at the outliers and looking
at the deviation between the model of
these family is what drives your next
iteration check out this big working day
by January I mean it's a very old
historical theme in statistics that you
should you should do area of model
building by looking at the difference
between experiment lab come and your
consist of dinner cooked in the crash to
this whoa mom bought office
included to see you have sure but I mean
I don't think like hey dude isn't it
there's a fine an extent to which my
experience has been here x generalizes
to everybody so i granted there's been a
lot of time on the lancet of like who I
work with who are all awesome and great
the pen you should come work at the no x
the novelist or something let me let me
use biological examples because it
didn't weigh very much more Universal
there just a few examples junk science
but they'll apply will be here later
this year speaking so when he gets here
telling the crystal adrees paper and
harass him about it fix I was hoping you
could help us understand
filled with life if I accomplish nothing
else as chief data scientist the new
york times i must accomplish like
yeah you know i'm i'm i'm building a
team setting a scientific tone for a
group of data scientists and
evangelizing for the powers of machine
learning throughout the company in a way
that doesn't do the service to your
judgment and healthy functioning of a
great company i agree that that's that's
broad but in fact i was hired without
without a specific manda I mean part of
that is you should understand that the
company is not static so you're joining
easily and you know people like to see
me to start this like trying to build a
plane while you're flying the plane and
running off the cliff it's not like that
pretty good because there's not there's
not a clutch but you know it is a
dynamic company so I wouldn't say that I
have one stack mandate but like there's
a budget that I surrounded by etl
engineers and date of his people they
sit surrounded by people who make sure
that the data are there enough quality
they are also interested in learning
from this bad one of the best ways to
learn from the data and actually to QA
today is to try to build statistical
models from those data you actually
learned a lot of things being broken and
you try to build statistical models from
did you learn that this knowledge and
it's great to work alongside these
people who helped you render the results
of those models just the visual display
of quantitative information challenge is
non-trivial so i would say that I've got
one player mandate I could die you know
my goals are to see that the same two
goals that I have in biology actually to
see how far this machine learning stuff
can be pushed and does it work you know
like we all have this for many of us
have a sense I'd like machine when it
doesn't kind of freakishly well
abundant data I'm kind of interested in
bringing it to the test in context where
it wasn't you know not like the UCI
dataset but like in single molecule
biology it doesn't work there does it
does it really learn you know that's the
kind of thing I'm interested in question
again you know like real world messy
data where you have to run a bunch of
MapReduce jobs before you're getting a
tournament to a tail please I'm teaching
CNN teaching classes chomp summer so
what do you think the importance of
almost most journals programmers I've
just inspected who can use Comic Con
yeah so the same thing with my safe
answer is no I cannot comment and so let
me get back to the original part of the
talk where I said near times as possum
data journalist people awesome computer
assisted reporting awesome interactive
graphics people awesome upshot people
I'm not doing any of that love those
people drop work with them talk with in
high five them that's not I'm gonna do
tonight did the safest answer for you
says no however when it comes to
Columbia yeah I'm really psyched about
judgment data journalism to students
this summer Mulligan using Python right
but yeah I mean like teaching data
journalism to people who want to become
a computation like the first one I want
to admission lighting me up and like
every going to miss you my muse Ramon
but i can remember going to a machine
money me up in january 2010 and normal
people wanted to hear about variational
bayesian methods and I was like this is
a strange new world so I'm very excited
for people who are going to build this
future of journalism put on a new
machine learning like I agree with
Jefferson that like given the choice
between a functioning democracy and
journalism UD journalism because they'll
make sure that your pumps being
democracy I think it's very blessed to
have functional journalism so I'm very
excited for those people to want to
learn from dead please
in the financial markets machine machine
learning has a problem in that models
aren't stable very very discontinuously
time what kind of humor up do you run
into those same problems and have you
check on the time scale for biology and
most web companies is different and it's
not adversarial but distributions are
dynamic so I mean even Netflix noses
it's not like it's not like planets has
the monopoly on the fact that the
distribution is dripping they like why
does what so when Netflix fries happen
the range gave a lot of talks about
their methods and what they basically
said was our method is an ensemble
method with like 300 methods darling but
one of the things they said was and we
throw away old data right so there are
there are many examples from the world
not just in finance where your data our
staff and you should throw a noble data
I can't think of one offhand where we
exploited that at the times with you
know it easily could happen where we
need to throw it all baby we do an
exponential moving average or so
historical average over everything I
don't know you know it might happen but
it's not as adversarial isn't finance
because people are trading against you
there are algorithms they're sniffing
each other out it's it's miss
all the sudden Congress readers are
aging the time
there's big cool spikes in the dam but I
mean I haven't I haven't worked out a
problem where I needed where that
something I'll messed up my ability to
learn from the day there may come a
problem there may come a day away need
to predict something and big a little
bit sir you know calves drop again
players that I have to take into account
but I have an encounter takako comment
how many problem i needed to do now i
just have like three more slides can I
do thousand the dude questions I'm
really wants done so I just want to
summarize so troubled a smarter way just
a personal sense so promoter a blessing
it so pressing on my body and I'll just
have some footer the footer is you know
there are you should pay attention to
the practices the skills in the culture
of data science you should demand them
either in yourself and people your
manage the practices evolve reframing
questions of machine learning try to be
wrong rather than not even wrong try to
be relevant try to know the difference
between having a paw this is just
getting handed the data side have been
asking more questions you can ask from
the data set make friends with
experimentalist it will be much more
effective the skills i think is
important to blank quantifiable rather
than just to make a bunch of plots cuz
that algorithm doesn't converge try the
dumbest thing possible first look for
small wins just make some regression
before you spend a lot of time on future
engineering and also be friends with or
be a date engineer in terms of cultural
i encourage everybody to came for being
communicative don't just do your crazy
enough craziness in a box and think that
you're going to not be fired be
skeptical of yourself and encourage
other people would be skeptical of you
be empowering and like making facile for
other people to reproduce your results
or break your code and let something
chron be transparent area code and
promote
promote the ability of other people to
do the same please you come find out
more if you have people who are looking
for a postdoc hiring the new york times
is always hiring all over the place if
you're running back in data science
design we're hiring and if you'd like to
talk over more of course will pop right
now and actually a week ago I just made
an outline for this talking's good
enough gifts don't get up so feel free
to issue a pull request or make a
comment on that there ok now that I've
finished up my shoe size
because I problem I like classifiers I
like fell one regular iced regression
like glm net with cross validation I
mean generally l1 regulars models are
easy to explain to people particularly
like there's a nugget that's linear I
just add these things up and then
there's a one so some of the things I
was in trouble you could say don't worry
about those things I like boosted
alternating decision trees again because
it's sparse but it requires somebody to
be willing to follow conditionally
important features so I know years ago
asked a question about model selection
to add a gentleman and he said no I
always thinking while section is a red
herring it just depends on having
coefficients the client is willing to
hear so I think it's very dependent on
who your audiences yeah I think it's
ready to know who you are in system I
problem you're trying to solve but
generally I like scars models and I like
something that has at least some linear
component to it so you could just say
imagine of adding all these factors the
truth is a lot of ml leads to EDA so
after you've done the ml and you've
identified what are the important
features out of hundreds of features go
do some exploratory data analysis on
those features just go do some
conditional instagrams with the things
that turned out to be important because
it may be a lot of it may be that you
used a big hammer and the big hammer was
great for separating wheat from chaff
and analytic and high dimensional space
of hypotheses but now you've identified
a handful of hypotheses now apply some
old-school EDA of those so maybe that a
lot of the story is there then the
high-powered high dimension on ml is
what leads you to the right smaller set
of features
please let's say that you're the first
data scientists are one of the first
data scientists hired by a
well-established company that's been
around for a while and there any number
of different areas that other operations
that can be optimized how do you decide
which problems are attacked first here's
what I would do hypothetically are you
good listener study the org chart figure
out what the people who are in power
fear and build a quantitative model that
predicts that thing next question
decide about the yeast you have to go
back to it but when you presented it to
experimental list yeah they said like oh
yeah this is obvious these are
interesting these are crazy did that
impact like how you thought about the
question or did you like where anything
else from that sure it dramatized me
announce days yeah so I mean one of the
things is i have to do the fishing
expedition before i go to the
experimentalists so it's a bit of a lazy
thing to go to the domain experts say
here so there's the stuff what do you
think so it's better for you do the
literature search first and figure out
this is obvious this is plausible
because it happens in palm bay so it
should happen in servici a right these i
don't really believe so then instead of
just saying hey what do you think you
should say hey look this first thing
turned out to be first and that's a good
sanity check so instead of saying it's
obvious you say this is reassuring my
model figures that is its first feature
this thing that we should think of us
and I think it's better to lead somebody
by the hand and say like here is an
awesome thing that we would publish in
science if you showed that this thing
actually shuts down cell cycle or
something
um something you said a minute ago
reminded me that when people think a
machine learning or running being a data
scientist hitting of running this model
you're running variational days or in
Marco Polo's or whatever and that's what
you're doing and that may be the end
product but along the way so much of
what you need to do pulls in either
exploratory data analysis as I seen your
data or had a post regression analysis
but looking at residuals and I find
those are the kinds of things that fall
into the holes of education yes we often
teach as if you know here's the model
which is still see the hypothesis and
reality is so much messier it's so much
more prone to miss coding that you know
whatever whenever you teach those basic
analytic skills how to draw a scatter
plot I just looking better I think
that's under emphasis totally agree in
fact four years ago I co-authored a blog
post called a taxonomy of data science
in which we talked about this sort of
process of data science obtaining data
scrubbing data boring data modeling data
and interpreting data and modeling data
is the little technology I'll teacher in
school like here's a class on supervised
learning here's an unsupervised learning
class rate everything else is hardly any
classes one of the reasons we created a
class and exploratory data analysis and
visualization at Columbia was the idea
that you know a lot of the
interpretation is drawing the right
chart right like knowing what finger to
draw even after you've done you know
your cross-validation test or whatever
is still not reading and exploring your
data in the beginning you know as I mean
turkey has a whole book on it right
exploratory data analysis is like it's
non-trivial so and certainly the data
engineering and the data scrubbing right
is not part of the usual education so I
agree so yeah so there's right there's
there's many ways of thinking about this
set of different tasks actually Rico out
that this blog posts are then Hadley
posted on the bottom actually it's not a
line
it's a loop because you always have to
iterate and after you've done some
interpretation right of course Hadley in
a way echoing you know box and great
statisticians from days of yore it day
plies recent paper you know that you go
and you look at the outliers and you
look at what your model gets wrong and
that educates you about what your next
model should be yes please wondering if
you have any practical tips for how to
promote literacy is you know it is a
data journalist one to struggle with the
serve you know once you go outside of
your averages and odds and simple ratios
percentage changes use
presenting at the general diesel
boy whatever so any tips for ya go look
at the upshot so at the upshot they'll
have a story sometimes they'll have an
interactive grad graphics and then at
the bottom they'll say if you want to
see the story for how we got these data
click here right so they have more than
one of the recent things as a whole blog
post basically about I read this article
once in this book and it mentioned this
factor passing and I thought holy
bejesus that means somewhere out there
there's a data set that says how each
individual quantile decile of the
economy has fared in these different
countries I have to find that data set
and then I looked in this place everyone
alright so that's the kind of thing that
you don't put in the main body of the
article but you empower other people by
talking about how you actually did that
and then click here for the github click
here for the Excel spreadsheet right so
I think there's a lot you can do to
empower people and if you're willing to
tell all those stores people in science
often talk about how we don't have a
journal front here a root problem
negative results right and you know in
different cultures of science you don't
have this sort of storytelling aspect
where when you present the talk you talk
about all the wrong turns you do right
there's no behaves limit on the Internet
so if you want to you could link to a
blog post where you talk about how hard
you work to get those data I don't know
about all the things you did wrong you
can link to the code in the end and the
repo right this is something i would say
in the name of representative the
computational sciences for half a decade
it's now happening in journalism right
mainstream media are making websites
that like to go link to get up and like
to excel spreadsheets stove we duel and
there's no page limit so do it
questions because interplay between
academia and New York Times my second
question is how specialized our data
scientists at New York Times what do you
divide the designs to sort data
scientists into iron health back end
right so the first question season
answer academia works well with tech
companies and the New York Times is
becoming rapidly a tech company so I
think attack attack interactions between
academia and tech companies are a good
idea right I think basically since you
let it backward launched in 1939 yeah
the record is pretty good academia and
tech companies good for the species and
the times is simply becoming a tech
company history i would say embody the
practices skills and culture of a data
scientist that you've learned in the lab
with your thumb and with your fingers
depending on whether you spend time as a
wet person or dry dry lab biologist
those are difficult skills and not just
the math skills but like the cultural
skills of trying to advance the science
using are those will benefit you when
you go into the world which is a mess
but biology is a mess tube which is
which is why you're well prepared your
second question about specialization
shirt people have different titles
there's a growing number of data
scientists in the near autonomous yeah
there's people running our own marketing
there's people running d3 the cubicle
next to me there's serious etl people
surrounding me you know who you might
call data engineers right you're
wonderful
five years ago now with almond data
engineers and those people are
reasonably specialized their titles
change all the time again something
that's weird to me about the real world
is like an academia title changes once
every three centuries in the real world
people's titles change so I thank you
know I don't know that their titles are
reflective of the specialization you're
looking for but yeah different people
everybody has a different sort of
spectrum of superpowers that they bring
to the table I couldn't do what I do
without making friends with the serious
ETL engineers so it's good different
people have some curious us to you know
what you as a cheap data scientists are
doing with your own user data show that
chart talk about it's not embodied you
guys doing through user data and bored
general
morning journalist yeah i'm happy to say
i don't make any of those decisions so
in terms of the org chart i'm far
removed from the newsroom in terms of
the elevator hang out with those people
all the time so we talk to each other i
don't actually have any authority over
the newsroom at all so they're having
their own conversations about the role
of metrics you know what is sacred and
what is profane about quantitative
things the things I'm interested in are
trying to inform business decisions or
even technical decisions using abundant
data about mostly the way people browse
but also you know how they subscribe how
they use all the different products you
may have noticed that the New York Times
has multiple products now like there's
multiple iphone apps that have been
launched and will launch in the near
future so there's the website there's
multiple ways of interacting with
maritime content there's just a lot of
data and there's a lot of problems even
irrespective of how the newsroom
operates which is fine because the
newsroom seems to be operating pretty
well that said they're not they're not
data foams I mean it's not like people
who it's not like when you start writing
for The New York Times you turn off your
Twitter account and Facebook I mean
these people are they live in 2014
they're aware of the internet so they're
not at all data phones it's just that in
terms of the org chart that's not the
that's not the change I'm trying to make
so we talked to the data journalist you
know high five great but that's not
quite a fun
or as soon as you come work with us once
I guess once I get un día de I'll review
all but other than that it's probably
better for me to talk about practices
and your culture particularly enjoyed
your comment about the importance of
being wrong or these potentially wrong
and it seems to me that's particularly
as the size and availability today that
it kind of blows up the number of ways
in which you can come up with a step to
make the Derek Jeter's best is growing
really really rapid oh yes yeah this was
something which while I was an academic
frustrated me tremendously is that it
seems like there are four more people
interested in finding of finding ways to
put dirt Jeter at the top of their
sadistic than are in like actually
answering falsifiable question and i was
wondering specifically in the context of
academia you know how do you see us kind
of handling this this problem right like
how do you overcome the fact that a
large portion of the academic community
community is essentially non-points
right they they don't speak
yes so look science is done by human
beings science is done by scientists and
scientists are human beings whether they
know their life or not so you know
scientists are going to do things that
human beings do they're going to want to
write a paper and you know when I did
get that Derek Jeter is the best or that
BRCA or so other important gene is
really important to publish and that's
that's good for their careers but
scientists are human beings what can we
do about that well we can shame them so
what can we do about it I mean we can
create a culture of people who are
critically literate in data science okay
so that Chuck that type of critical
literacy is when you pick up a paper in
nature and it says we found that Derek
Jeter was the best or some equivalent
see supplemental figure 5 you look at
supplemental figure 5 and you download
their code and when their code says you
know online 137 printf Derek Jeter is
the best then you write a scathing blog
post that directs everybody it's a lime
137 and some people are doing that I
don't necessarily advocate that for your
career until maybe your tenured but once
your tenured you know bring out that's
your moral obligation to the students
just like to indoctrinate young people
before they read some paper and think
well as published in science I guess
Derek Jeter's best please
logo turtle I don't know how I started
coding in the 70s in basic and then I
they made me take AP calculus which at
the time was in Pascal now it's a Java
then I became a scientific computation
person and somebody SAT me down in a
windowless room with a spark 360 and
said here's a book on unix here's a book
on 4chan here's a book on chaotic
dynamical systems see in three months
and that's what I did right I say go to
the UNIX tutorial for VI and I did that
so I started out in Fortran I did
Fortran for from the 80s to the
beginning of this century then I started
using matlab book to visualize the
output from my poor train then I started
using matlab for real and then i started
using barn python to keep up with my
students because they were doing things
that i didn't understand and now i speak
really bad or a little bit of really bad
python mostly thanks to this that's a
life here's what I speak shell the truth
is what I speak if I write a lot of
shell scripts because a lot of data
science is obtaining extend like magic
data and at the last possible minute it
becomes a my falutin language like our
but like it's almost entirely shell
scripts until the last possible minute
please if you let if you're doing AP
tests back to like
for a while and eventually
and not even controlling for the fashion
a lot of these programs are can Ruby or
Python so and also you know p value
issues yes I'm not a p-value person I
tend to choose a model that's most
predictive on held out data that's just
short of my mindset I should clarify
though that I'm not a navy person who
friends were the AV people the rock the
left now high fives but i'm not actually
personally during AP tests which means
i'm also not during p-values to advocate
when to stop during a few guys maybe
does it's a hard problem not my problem
props to take profit drops to the people
that have to deal with it in terms of
p-values i tend not to speak p values
but i tend to speak is there's a
countably finite but like really large
number of models and i want a model that
is the most predictive if i want to put
a p-value on it I can but that provides
that mandates that I'm going to tell you
with the null model is in most cases
that's a non-trivial task to start with
the null model is if it's supervised
learning task then I can usually
generate empirically a null model under
permutation testing even then I have to
say I'm gonna prove you my labels what's
sacred was prepaid what set of
covariance I am I going to mandate they
stay the same what set of covariance I'm
going to allow to vary repre- and at the
end of it you have something that's like
a mortgage rate where you can spoil down
to a single number but you really have
to look at all the fine print to know if
you're being swindled which is why which
is why I tend not to and to embark on
p-value ology unless the referee demands
it
I write down I read a hypothesis space a
set of many many models and I attempt to
make those models out of features that
are individually interpretable and then
I use the right math which is
generically machine learning in order
not only not to overfit the data but to
find the models that are most predictive
on how that data and the models that are
most predictive on the help on the held
out models of how that data are the
models that allow me to sleep best at
night and I could do that without ever
saying the work you got you but I can
often do it without even saying the word
probability loss function optimization
that's my mindset thanks good so I
forward to discussing morn at the after
party the Charles blue tolerated